welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and Netflix have
just dropped their answer to lost with
the limited series the island that just
launched on the platform today if the
show's ending left you well lost then
don't worry because I'm here to break
down everything that you need to know
about the series and its final few
scenes there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
all seven episodes yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of the island we
follow a group of people that
mysteriously wake up on the shores of an
island with no idea how they got there
or what exactly is going on each one of
them has been given an object and the
enigmatic season really captures your
interest from the beginning the real
drive of the season is about an earthing
exactly who they are and why they've
been seemingly chosen to be there some
of the group show real leadership
qualities others alienate themselves
some even just want to sit around in
sunbathe and some have never seen jaws
before so yeah they get attacked by
sharks and deserved to die
don't app me it should be a paradise but
everything starts to fall apart after
one of the characters is sexually
assaulted the series sort of takes the
stands are the me2 movement with a
female character making accusations
about the attack and the males kind of
denouncing it even though we could see
that it did indeed happen the character
even has a shell which when blown in two
sounds like a horn which yeah is a bit
on the nose but she raises the alarm on
things and the person who attacked it
goes unchecked and continues to do it to
others
gaining positions of power throughout
the introduction which yeah it's a
metaphor for people in positions of
power constantly getting overlooked ten
years ago this would have been
cutting-edge but these days especially I
feel like people are called out on
things like this quickly cancelled and
thus the commentary feels a bit outdated
the show is laced with things like this
and there's many metaphors for how
people are demonized and manipulated
into certain ways of thinking by certain
authority figures there's victim blaming
paranoia and fake news all put together
on the island to make a statement about
how
we as people and a society operate what
it boils down to though is an almost
Hunger Games esque fight for survival
against a shadowy organization that put
them in the circumstances to study them
the main character chase played by
Natalie Martinez is constantly pulled in
and out of the island
and we discovered that the entire
exercise is a simulation designed to
study nature versus nurture and if
external circumstances dictate
personality with their memories arrays
the overseers wish to see if some people
are just inherently evil that will
always do wrong no matter what it's very
esoteric and I think that mind hunters
studied the subject much better without
hitting people over the head the shell
thinks it's a lot smarter than it is and
for something that is supposedly showing
the true nature of humans seems to be
far more focused on stereotypes rather
than discussing true psychology each one
of the group is a death row inmate that
has a shady past and the experiment is
put in place to attempt to rehabilitate
those who haven't led such a decent life
thus far it's largely car make and those
who do evil acts end up getting paid
back by the island in one form or
another it's punishment the group slowly
come to remember their history and some
are even shocked by what they've done
including Casey played by Kate Bosworth
who can't come to grips with the fact
that after cheating on her abusive
husband she killed her own children Jude
him stating that if she left she'd never
see them again it's pretty messed up and
Bosworth becomes the best actor in the
show after her backstory centric episode
and we watch as she slowly breaks
haunted by the specter of her children
and it's probably the standout in the
series even the happy moments such as a
budding romance ends up being a seedy
stalker story and yeah it's pretty much
hell on earth or in a simulation let's
divide and play every man for themselves
and some tried to flee to other islands
to bite off more than they can chew
literally and it's slowly spirals into
chaos chase herself discovers that she
has a shared history with another
Islander and that they had a
relationship after being together in the
Armed Forces both are haunted by visions
of chases mother and similar to Casey
they slowly start to piece together
their backstory whilst initially the
audience is led to believe that chase
killed her mother it was in fact an
accidental death when chases husband
Cooper and her mother fought over a gun
it went off and as Cooper confesses to
the crime chases exonerated and
Freed's and we discovered that the
warden is the evil mastermind behind it
all
afraid that chase wants free will
announce to the public that he was
trying to sabotage the program to show
that those on death row don't deserve to
live he attempts to talk her out of it
it's very much a comment on
rehabilitation as a whole and it does
weigh up the pros and cons of the death
penalty and how many view killing
killers for killing is a contradiction
the final episode kind of breaks down
just how ridiculous the entire
experiment is as an idea with the sharks
in it and yet it just says that this
isn't a good way to rehabilitate people
after Chase gives a statement the warden
is caught red-handed trying to kill her
and hold on to your butts because
there's one more final twist in the
entire thing
chase learns that the Islanders go into
the simulation at the age that they
committed the crime and that she has
actually served the majority of a life
sentence already and is now quite
elderly the series ends with Chase
learning that even though she was
screwed over she must learn to forgive
and the redemption that she found in the
program as well as the truth is a reward
in its own way which okay I guess she's
finally allowed to leave and she heads
out into the world to live her life
Chase is no longer judgmental and afraid
in her mind and therefore she is free we
then see the warden waking up on the
island with Cooper and KC holding Spears
over him which showcases that because of
his judgmental side that he's now
trapped in a prison of his own making
due to his prejudices and that he will
have to get used to island life we end
with the two worlds flipped of a man in
power now becoming a prisoner and a
woman who was a prisoner being set free
and overall it can be seen as an analogy
for feminism and how the weak are
currently rising up in society to take
over those who remained in power for
centuries but what did I think of this
show overall well the island is okay I
guess I feel like through our it was
pretty predictable and well it does
still have some surprises the
over-the-top social commentary is hard
to ignore it all feels heavy-handed
rather than subtle and this makes the
show sometimes I rollin ly bad
especially with the amount of
stereotypes that are there this is
purely down to execution and whilst
there are a number of elements that work
as well as several performances that
feel gripping but a show that's trying
to Abe lost inception and the matrix it
falls flat in several ways it's not out
in our bad either and at
seven episodes it's quite an easy binge
or something to put on in the background
when you're working but as a piece of
television I feel like there are better
things to watch this weekend overall I
didn't hate the island but I didn't love
it either and that's why it gets a six
out of ten obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the island and what you
took from it do you agree or disagree
with me and what would you score the
show comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of Netflix's the spy which
will be linked after this I go over
everything you need to know about the
show and the real-life events that
inspired it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want something else
to watch if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books and you can pull them in twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this also just wanna let you
know that we're giving away a free copy
of spider-man far from home on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
island in the comments section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then to have a good
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
do you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]